chris weber kevin garnett dirk nowitzki
rasheed wallace that was like my first
five games in the nba like i always just
been into making money in a sense of
like i don't like to spend it i like to
see it stack
this is the reunion where former college
athletes meet up to talk lessons learned
about sports money and life
all right carlos and renee both
champions in college went on to have
tremendous careers but when you look
back at your respective careers what do
you feel like led you to become
champions i'll start with you
i would say just the grind like i
learned how to
get it in through the work so a lot of
times you don't know how to get there
you know you even see lebron left
cleveland to learn how to win a
championship i learned how to win a
championship in college and so you start
to once you see how it's done then you
know how to repeat it or you know what
it feels like when you're on that team
where it's like yeah this feels right so
that's really where i learned all that
i agree 100 yeah those extra nice you
got extra shots up those extra sprints
that coach wanted you to run so you're
in the best tip top shape the extra
stuff that you put in is what gets you
over the hump so never cut corners yeah
basketball was a way to get me to see
the world and so i wanted to to see what
it was like elsewhere and i knew that
you know everybody would talk about the
new york hoopers or the cali hoopers and
so i wanted to be where it's at like i
wanted to i didn't know where i felt in
that group of people because i'm not
playing against the competition that
they are but i knew that basketball
could get me there so it was a means to
get in somewhere else it was i wanted to
get on the big stage yeah no matter if i
made it to the league or not i'd still
be playing basketball bottom line is
in that you end up learning that oh i
can monetize this let me let me be as
good as i can be so i can get the most
monetization out of this you know what i
mean how did you learn about money in
college or did you learn about money in
college or did that come later i didn't
come from a lot of bread i came from the
gutter like like most people in my
profession and so we didn't have a bunch
of money going around so i didn't know
taxes and how to invest and these are
all terms that were foreign to me when i
got to the league so i had to go through
you know some of the heartaches of
making a bad investment to learn what a
good investment was going through it and
living it and making the mistakes
and then as i got older i stopped making
those same mistakes
i would say this is the the grittiest me
that there is out there right there
oh absolutely
let's talk a bit about your journey from
college to the pros um when you look
kind of at that time what was the
biggest adjustment between the two
losing uh
it sounds so simple but i had to really
get used to like you know when you lose
in college i can be mad for a couple
days you know i can be mad and train and
get it out of my system you lose in the
pros you might have a game tomorrow and
no one like you don't you have to have
that short term memory so i would just
say like every night you had to you just
had to come ready every night for me
also was the same thing like one the
competition right the best in the world
one dude even the guys that don't play
are nice
my first week in the league was like
chris webber kevin garnett dirk nowitzki
mailman carl malone it was like that's
the first rasheed wallace that was like
my first five games in the nba there's
no
nights off so you are both business
people and athletes
what characteristics or traits you know
on the court translate to business
oh man so with with my foundation rmf i
literally that's the the mission
statement because sports taught me
discipline teamwork confidence like all
of those things that if you put that as
a skill set for a job just any job not
even just an investor people like are
you a good leader yeah how do you know
oh i led a team for for 15 years oh you
are a leader oh are you good at
discipline and time work and managing
your time oh yeah i've never been like
the practice duh i'm not allowed to like
you start to see things that are just
like confidence i would say
something i took from sports into the
business world would be like the
scouting report you know we talked about
doing your due diligence and doing your
homework do the same thing in business
like like just like we go on the court
and you're checking this seat they like
to go right they got to go left they got
a fall away based on are they a good
free throw shooter in the clutch same
thing with the investment is it going to
make you money right away is it a long
term play do you do your scouting report
on the business idea when you got
drafted did you think oh my god i'm rich
i didn't
earn my keep my agent was like you gotta
go to someone they can go crush it and
then they're gonna give you a deal i was
like say less yeah so i went to summer
league i was like 25 and 15.
okay crush the summer
and then at that time they usually gave
second round picks a one-year deal
they gave me a two-year deal with a
third year option i had played so well
so
you know i didn't feel necessarily rich
but i felt like i could earn what i
deserve and that's what i did if your
whole idea is to get rich and you're
looking on a career path i don't know if
the wnba is that and there's different
ideas of what is rich but my first
thought was
i need to go prove myself like i wasn't
about the finances it was about the like
wow okay so let me see what i can do at
this level but then when i got my first
check i did feel rich
he's like i don't care what that check
was about to say baby i'm making checks
it says my name on it right here this is
mine i walked to the bank yeah this is
for mrs montgomery and that is she i am
her
i don't care what it said i really did
feel cause i went from making nothing to
actually making some money so i i felt
rich and maybe it wasn't
watching yourself what do you first
think about when you think about your
time there first i'm like whoa i was
young like tattoos
so when you look at the financial
landscape that you both have right now
what do you want that to be 10 years
from now so i own like 18 popeyes and a
couple of uh tropical smoothies and a
couple of starbucks and i was trying to
find something that would like
create generational wealth not just for
me but for everybody you know what i
mean so i own part of it my son's on
part of it i have some partners of mine
as well not only do we own the
operations but we also own the real
estate a good mentor mentor mind is shaq
and if you look at his
his portfolio shaq has every kind of
burger kings and five guys and
everything you could think of and that's
how he was able to get generational
wealth after his career too so i'm kind
of taking a tip off my big bro and doing
the same thing i'm just generational
wealth that's that that word is a real
word that i think i'm so glad to hear
you say it out loud that means growing
that means you know owning things in a
sense of think tank productions you know
i'm watching what everybody else is
doing now we have our own production
company and so that's me not having to
work for my money my money is now
working for me that's that's what i hope
to see in 10 years absolutely talking
about money can be intimidating
especially to younger folks
what is something you would say to them
to know like it's okay to ask those
questions and it's okay to be a little
scared what you have to do is ask for
the younger generation our younger
audience don't be afraid to ask the
question raise your like we talked about
before raise your hand and ask why or
ask how or ask when and don't be afraid
to find out and don't be afraid to to be
in a room with people who know more than
you
[Music]